[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills election results are coming in
but we are still waiting for results
from a selection of
key battleground states right now we're
seeing that biden is at 209 electoral
votes and trump is
at 118. we're still waiting for more
information from key states like florida
north carolina ohio texas and more but
we have an
expert from bloomberg jeff taylor here
joining us to tell us more about what we
can expect to come
from these key states jeff thank you so
much for joining us
first off can you just walk me through
the latest on where we're at with some
of the
recent data we're getting from these
election results tonight
well the script has largely gone as
expected this evening so far
i mean biden has won the states that
he's been expected to win
mostly urban states in the north and the
west
and trump has won the states that he's
been expected to win
um the the big southern states states
across the sun belt
and now we're getting down to the nitty
gritty of it which is the
midwestern battleground states the
so-called battleground states they're
not all in the midwest but many of them
are
the biggest ones are and that's where
the election probably will be truly
decided those states include
pennsylvania wisconsin michigan
and i understand fox news called arizona
which is considered a battleground state
for biden
but the others are very closely fought
and that's actually probably where this
thing will get decided
you mentioned that fox news called
arizona for biden and the
trump campaign is refuting that claim
can you talk to me a little bit about
that process and
what this means for what contested
election results could look like in
other states moving forward
well arizona's you know been changing i
mean the demographic in arizona is
becoming younger
more latino more asian and the
democratic strength in that state has
been growing it's also a state
that's comfortable with mail-in voting
unlike a lot of the states that we're
talking about like pennsylvania
mainland voting is you know relatively
new to the electorate there but in
arizona they've been doing it for years
60 percent of the voting in most
elections in arizona is done by mail
so you know for all these reasons i
think you know
um uh some people think you know that
mail-in voters who are largely
democratic may lift
biden to victory but as you say trump is
disputing you know fox news's call of
the state
and other networks have not called it
yet so it may be the case that it you
know it has hasn't actually carried for
biden
just yet he certainly um in the
broadcast that i've seen he's been
leading in the precincts that are
reporting so far biden is
and in this state that is so accustomed
to mail and voting
and before we started this live you and
i were talking about this idea of a red
mirage and whether
we're seeing higher numbers for trump
because of people coming in and voting
in person today
while uh mail-in and absentee ballots
are still going to be
counted for some days to come and some
of these key battleground states can you
talk me through
what the timeline is looking like in
states like pennsylvania
well i mean it could take days you know
it could be till friday
you know or even later um you know the
democratic lawyers in trying to get
mail-in vote to be adopted as
deeply and as widely as possible during
this pandemic
obtained a ruling from the state supreme
court of pennsylvania
that says that as long as a mail-in
ballot is posted by election day
it must be counted if it's received
within three days of election day
so they'll be counting ballots that are
coming in for some days to come
and if the state is really close uh
they'll also be litigating over those
ballots
um so you know this gives you this is
just one
of the battleground states that we're
discussing so this gives you a sense of
how
you know the quick results today's
results tonight's results
may be in question for some time to come
some days to come
and can you talk me through what both
the trump and biden campaigns have done
to prepare for
any litigation that may come from a
contested election result
well they both they both laid in
literally dozens of lawyers in states
all across the country
in these battleground states that we're
discussing and also in other states
and they litigated ahead of the election
in advance of the election to try to
gain advantage
over mail-in ballots and other issues
like drive-in voting
and the number of days after the
election by which
ballots can be returned all of this has
been fought out in court
in advance of the election and you know
a lot of people see that as merely a
dress rehearsal
for the bigger fight over actual ballots
as they are returned
um just to get into the pennsylvania
case that i mentioned for a moment it's
about
hundreds of potentially hundreds of
thousands of absentee ballots
mailed in by voters in pennsylvania that
may have some defect or other the
signature may look strange
there may be some problem with it some
technical problem with it
the secretary of state of pennsylvania
wants to allow
people who voted in that way to come in
as
cure what is called curing the defective
absentee ballot by using a provisional
ballot which is kind of a secondary
ballot they use in a situation like that
a republican u.s representative has sued
to block that
and actually though that sounds esoteric
you know the outcome of pennsylvania
could come down to something like that
and i'm wondering what your message is
to um
maybe biden supporters who are a little
bit upset tonight and trump
supporters who are excited what's your
message to people who are
essentially getting ready to call this
election already one way or the other
i think i think what i'm picking up you
know from the news reports that i've
been
reading and from the reporting that
we've been doing as a news organization
is just that it's
very very close and it's probably too
early for either side
um to get excited or despondent about
these results
i think in these states that we're
discussing in the wisconsins the
michigans the pennsylvanias the ohios
i think in those states we just won't
know
what the outcome is for a while um maybe
we'll know when we wake up tomorrow or
maybe it will be even later than that as
we were discussing before
and so to for either side to get very
excited about
what it appears with the what the
returns appear to be
into in today's voting in the in-person
voting today is probably premature
probably this whole process has to play
out all the counting
all the votes the absentee votes the
mail-in votes
provisional votes sent in from people
overseas americans living overseas
and then any legal issues associated
with all these late arriving and late
counted votes also has to get resolved
so what appears to be the case today may
not appear to be the case in a couple of
days we have to wait and let the process
play out
and i'm wondering how tonight's uh
results
clear up with uh anticipation from the
biden and trump campaigns
um did either side see things being this
close
uh based on your conversations with
folks on the campaigns
well you hear you know you hear people
in the obama
biden you know world saying you know
don't be surprised don't be shocked and
appalled this is what we thought was
going to happen you know we thought that
day of voting was going to go for the
president
um because in many of these southern
states and many of these sunbelt states
people prefer to vote on the day of the
election as opposed to
mailing in ballots which they are wary
of
um because the president is wary of
mail-in ballots and has actually warned
you know very specifically you know that
he believes that mail-in ballots can in
many cases be fraudulent
um so you know culturally people in
these places
you know that support trump tend to vote
on the day up so
as the votes come pouring in on the day
of for trump
what biden and obama would say is yeah
that's to be expected
now we need to count all the votes you
know including the absentee ones the
mail-in votes
and then we'll find out who really won
so so that's what they would say in this
situation
is you know you know don't get too
excited don't jump to conclusions
this thing needs to play out in full
before we'll know
and as a reporter what are you going to
be looking for
in terms of updates throughout the night
tonight and tomorrow to really guide the
way that you're thinking about
how this election is going to shake out
well i think you got to watch these
counts closely in all these states that
we're talking about i mean honestly but
you know up to the point when we started
this conversation you know i hadn't seen
many surprises
i mean i had you know i i had mostly
seen states fall into line
according to what was expected you know
bide was expected to win new york and
california he did trump was expected to
win texas and georgia
he did you know so you know it's when
the surprises start to tumble in
states in in the in the battleground
category that
you know no one is quite sure you know
you know are to go to one camp or the
other you know
biden had a lead in the most recent you
know pennsylvania polls if someone
you know if credible news news services
call pennsylvania for trump
that would be significant you know that
would that would be a big deal um what's
happening in florida where trump is
leading at the moment is a big deal
um it's these battleground states and so
that's what i'll be watching and then
then i think we move you know madison to
the second act and the second act is
okay what legal act what legal issues
get raised in the aftermath of the votes
being counted
and that's where i think you may recall
in
bush versus gore 2000 you know the case
was ultimately
decided by the supreme court who decided
to rule out a number of ballots based on
technical grounds
and it really could come down to some
kind if it's a very close election
it could come down to you know a legal
fight over particular issues in one of
these battleground states
you mentioned bush v gore and bush
at the time sort of declared victory a
little bit early i'm wondering if you
think that trump or biden will
kind of copy that tactic uh if they're
concerned
about this election result going all the
way to scotus
it's hard to say you know trump has said
that he'll you know
if it's very close and he believes some
of the some of the ballots
you know aren't are you know are
fraudulent he'll go to court um
whether he'll come out and declare
victory before the count is completed
i don't know i mean i you know i i can't
say whether he would do that or not
biden has already said um that if the
count tonight is very close he may not
speak to his supporters tonight he may
wait until tomorrow
when he hopes that a clearer picture has
emerged
and is there anything else that you are
looking to
tonight and tomorrow that we haven't
already talked about in terms of just
guiding your
understanding of how uh the litigation
surrounding any potential contested
results could shake out for either
candidate
well i think you have to look at if you
if you want to try to anticipate you
know where the litigation
may go and what the most significant
issues in the lawsuits
may be i think you want to look at
heavily democratic counties and areas i
think that
the republicans have been preparing and
planning to
file lines of legal attack to try to
devalidate
ballots in heavily democratic
strongholds
like philadelphia detroit um
atlanta for if they need to for a long
time so that's where i would look
for those who want to really try to
understand you know what the potentially
complex litigation
you know that may follow you know the
vote counting may be
i i think it may center on um ballots
and democratic areas where trump lawyers
um try to use different tactics to um
declare invalid um large numbers
as many as many ballots from those areas
as they possibly can to try to swing the
balance for the president
and one final question for you jeff
before we let you go i know you have a
lot of coverage to get to
um our audience has asked a lot about
the potential of president trump
refusing to leave
office what do you think the likelihood
is of that occurring and how would the
president potentially
pull that off you know i was speaking to
an academic
a professor a lawyer in marymount
university um
in la justin levitt is his name he
tracks election litigation
about this very topic and he spoke
soothing words the words are
that won't happen there will be an
outcome there will be a winner
and um the winner on on january 20th
will occupy the white house
if trump's the winner he will occupy the
white house if biden's the winner he
will occupy the white house the secret
service
the other aspects of the us government
the senate the house
no institution of u.s power would have
it any other way you know
that's what he says and i tend to agree
with that i tend to think that
after this process that you and i have
been discussing the counting and then
the litigating unfortunately
will have a winner you know there will
be a declared winner as there was
in in florida 2000 you know in bush b
gore
and and that winner whoever it may be
whether it's by whether it's trump
is the person who'll occupy the white
house as of january 20th
that's the law and i'm quite optimistic
that the law will be upheld in that
regard
and a heavy-handed question for you jeff
do you
have a prediction of uh the date or
timeline where we will have
a result for this election all i can say
is to sort of
you know drift in the direction that i
was going before i think it may be a few
days personally
just because of the complexity of the
issues
and the threat of litigation i think
it's going to be very very close
it appears that it appears it's going to
be very very close
states like pennsylvania as we were
discussing earlier may be counting
ballots for some days pennsylvania is
absolutely critical to the outcome and
there are the legal issues that we
discussed
so that all adds up to the fact that
before we have a conclusive
winner that we all know is the winner it
may be a little while because you got it
takes some time to work through these
issues
and i also want to add that we are
hearing from the associated press that
joe biden
uh won minnesota uh jeff we are getting
a lot of new
viewers with us so before we let you go
i'm going to keep you a little longer
because of these viewers here
uh i want i want to ask you to just
recap some of the information you told
me about the latest election results
we're getting tonight where are we
and what should people be looking to uh
as they follow this coverage throughout
the night
well states like minnesota are
incredibly significant um
it's these midwestern battleground
states as you and i were discussing that
are probably going to decide the
election it's you know
pennsylvania wisconsin michigan
arizona those are the states you know
those are the states where we'll see
a surprise perhaps one way or the other
those are the states that are hard
fought
both in terms of balloting campaigning
and also in terms of litigation that may
follow
um you know the vote counting and i
really feel like the states like those
four
you know are the ones that are likely to
to determine the outcome here
um what we've seen so far with only a
couple of exceptions i guess you could
point to minnesota as
significant but what we've seen so far
as we were discussing earlier is
results that were expected um trump kind
of swept the board so far
in you know southern significant
southern and sun belt states
biden has won the big western states
like california where i am
washington state new york new jersey
in the northern urban states that he was
expected to win so
by and large so far with with the states
where voting voting is complete enough
for news organizations to have made a
call it's pretty much according to
plan it's pretty much according to
expectation it's what happens in these
other states that we're discussing
the battleground states like the ones
that we mentioned that's what's probably
going to determine the election
and one potential outcome we haven't
talked about at all is the potential for
a tie i know that's pretty unlikely
but just for the sake of argument here
if there is a tie in the electoral
college what will happen
uh if there's a tie in the electoral
college that's the process that
commences it goes to the house of
representatives is my understanding
i do and i do believe that that's a
pretty unlikely outcome
i think i think more likely is that
we'll just get a very very close
decision where
the number of electoral college votes
required to install someone as a
president will be reached
but not in an overwhelming way and
certainly not in the sort of blue wave
way that some some democrats were hoping
for
nor in the um sort of
red um rally way that i think some
republicans are hoping for as they look
at the
returns that are coming in today i think
it's going to be very very close though
not a tie
and i think in the end that's what's
going to probably propel this thing
as you and i discussed earlier to the
courts where a number of issues will be
litigated
um in in coming days to try to validate
or invalidate some of these
some of these ballots so it's maybe not
the most ideal thing but i think it's
going to take a while to parse through
all this
and what's the path look like to get
this
brought up in courts if the election
results are
uh really slim between trump and biden
what what would either candidate have to
do
to kind of get this contentious result
reviewed by scotus for example
well so that's a that's a great question
and i think that goes to that goes to
the specific cases that we touched on
earlier but didn't go into depth about
so in pennsylvania there are two
lawsuits
that i think could be quite significant
in this regard and they're a good
example of how it might be fought in
other states or maybe it's just
pennsylvania that emerges as the most
important
you know of the states in the litigation
environment
but in those two lawsuits you know
earlier today
it's it's it's still tuesday right yes
so
on the west coast it is and you know on
the east coast it's not but on on monday
a lawsuit was filed in federal court in
philadelphia by
by republican lawyers against montgomery
county election officials
that's a suburban philadelphia county uh
heavily democratic where the
local election officials said that
mail-in ballots absentee ballots that
were found to be defective
they were going to give those voters an
opportunity to correct the defects
or to cure those ballots and and
fill out new provisional ballots so that
their votes could be counted
so republican lawyers filed a lawsuit
trying to block that
there's a hearing in that case tomorrow
morning in federal court in philadelphia
and then the new development tonight
that i was writing about tonight
is that a state court lawsuit in
pennsylvania was
was filed that broadened that issue
about the validity of absentee ballots
and curing them with provisional ballots
statewide it
took what was a what was a fight in one
suburban philadelphia county
to to the whole state so and
and one and that that case is in state
court so it would be heard by a state
court judge
and as it proceeds up the line in
pennsylvania as it probably would if
it's in hot dispute
to the state supreme court and there's a
ruling by the state supreme court
the u.s supreme court has tended to
provide deference
to state courts in deciding such issues
so that's
why republican lawyers filed a case to
try to apply
that same argument to absentee ballots
statewide because it's hundreds of
thousands of ballots that might be found
to be detected
defective statewide and trump only won
pennsylvania in 2016 by
44 000 votes right so if there's
hundreds of thousands
of ballots statewide in pennsylvania
that can be called into question
through this lawsuit you see the
significance of it i mean if they can
invalidate hundreds of thousands of
votes you know potentially it could
swing the election that's the sort of
thing
that to your in answer to your question
the lawsuits we'll be fighting about
jeff thank you so much for that i do
want to point out to our viewers that
the associated press is calling
ohio and iowa for president trump and
calling minnesota again
for joe biden as we're getting this
breaking news jeff what do you think
about those state
developments does that uh does that
shake out any
uh further thoughts for you on when and
how we might hear the results of this
election
they're both very significant states i
mean they're all there all three of
those are very significant states and
they're the battleground states you know
that that we were discussing i mean
they're among the battleground states we
were discussing i think that um
biden had hope of winning iowa
there are three counties in particular
in iowa
democratic leaning where some of the
bigger cities are
where the biden camp had hoped you know
the vote tally would
might carry that traditionally
republican state in their favor but
it is a traditionally republican state
you know and one that president
trump won easily four years ago he also
won ohio four years ago
so you know at some point along the line
here biden needs to win
states that hillary clinton lost four
years ago
ohio was such a state i think biden had
hoped
um to to win in ohio so that you know
that's a significant loss
minnesota is a significant win however
um and and i
and i have to go back you know we have
to go back to the same four states that
you and i were talking about earlier
which are you know probably where the
election will be decided which is
pennsylvania wisconsin michigan and
arizona
yes the states that you mentioned that
have been called in one direction or
another are quite significant
and these four that i'm that i'm
mentioning now
are very significant as well and maybe
where this election will get decided
and final question for you jeff which i
know i told you what feels like an hour
ago but i promise i'm telling the truth
this time
uh if uh florida and texas go
to trump which it's looking right now in
the numbers that
both of them will uh how hard will it be
for biden to sneak ahead
in this election well once again i think
you got a path i mean there's a path for
biden
if some of those four states that i
mentioned do carry for him
but if trump gets texas and florida
and ohio as he already has been called
as having ohio
um and then he also gets um some of the
bigger states on the list that i
mentioned
uh pennsylvania michigan wisconsin then
it's then it starts to get hard
um at the moment with with those four
states in play that i'm talking about
there's a there's a path for 270 votes
for biden
but if some of those four states that
we're talking about start to get caught
for trump then it gets much harder
jeff i know you have a lot of coverage
to get to so we're going to let you go
but thank you so much for
this incredibly illuminating
conversation and thank you to all of our
viewers who are following who followed
us throughout the night on this election
coverage
uh we're going to continue to bring you
all of the breaking news that you need
so follow us here on quick take for more
thank you so much